الله اكبر الله
اكبر اشهد ان لا اله الا
الله اشهد ان محمدا رسول
الله حي على
الصلاه حي على
الفلاح قد قامت
الصلاه قد قامت
الصلاه الله اكبر الله اكبر لا اله الا
الله
استقيم واعتدل واستو سو الصف سد
الخلل الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الضال
امين وما ارسلنا قبلك من المرسلين الا
انهم لياكلون الطعام ويمشون في
الاسواق وجعلنا بعضكم لبعض فتنه
اتصبرون وكان ربك بصيرا
وقال الذين لا يرجون
لقاءنا لولا انزل علينا الملائكه او نرى
ربنا لقد استكبروا في انفسهم وعتوا عتوا
كبيرا يوم يرون الملائكه لا بشرى يومئذ
للمجرمين ويقولون حجرا
محجورا وقدمنا الى ما عملوا من عمل
فجعلناه
هباء
منثورا اصحاب الجنه يومئذ خير
مستقر خير
مستقرا واحسن
مقيلا ويوم تشقق
السماء بالغمام ونزل
الملائكه
تنزيلا الملك يومئذ الحق
للرحمن وكان يوما على الكافرين
عسيرا ويوم يعض الظالم على يديه يقول يا
ليتني اتخذت مع الرسول سبيل
يا ويلت ليتني لم اتخذ فلانا
خليلا لقد اضلني عن الذكر بعد اذ
جاءني وكان الشيطان
للانسان
خذولا الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستق قيم صراط
الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وقال الرسول يا رب ان قومي اتخذوا
هذا القران
مهجورا
وكذلك نا لكل نبي
عدوا من
المجرمين وكفى بربك
هاديا
ونصيرا وقال الذين كفروا لولا نزل عليه
القران جمله
واحده كذلك لنثبت به فؤادك ورتلناه
ترتيلا لا ياتونك بمثل الا جئناك بالحق
واحسن
تفسيرا الذين يحشرون على وجوههم الى
جهنم
اولئك شر مكانا واضل
سبيلا ولقد اتينا موسى الكتاب وجعلنا معه
اخا هارون
وزيرا فقلنا اذهبا الى القوم الذين كذبوا
باياتنا
فدمرناهم
تدميرا وقوم نوح لما كذبوا الرسل
اغرقناهم وجعلناهم
للناس ايه واعتدنا للظالمين
عذابا
اليما وعادا وثمود واصحاب الرس
وقرونا بين ذلك
كثيرا
وكلا ضربنا له
الامثال
وكلا
تبرنا
تتبيرا الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر سمع
الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
ن مزز
بس
[Silence]
استقيم اعتدل
استو استووا استووا الصف
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين ولقد اتوا على القريه التي امطرت مطر
السوء افلم يكونوا
يرونها بل كانوا لا يرجون
نشورا واذا راوك ان يتخذونك الا هزوا اهذا
الذي بعث الله رسولا ان كاد ليضلنا عن
الهتنا لولا ان صبرنا
عليها وسوف يعلمون حين يرون العذاب من اضل
سبيلا ارايت من اتخذ الى اله هواه افانت
تكون عليه
وكيلا ام تحسب ان اكثرهم يسمعون او
يعقلون ان هم الا كالانعام بل هم اضل
سبيلا الم تر الى ربك كيف مد الظل ولو
شاء لجعله
ساكنا ثم ث جعلنا الشمس عليه
دليلا
ثم قبضناه الينا قبضا
يسيرا وهو الذي جعل لكم الليل لباسا
والنوم
سباتا وجعل
النهار
نشورا وهو الذي ارسل الرياح بشرا بين يدي
رحمته
وانزلنا من
السماء
ماء
طهورا لنحيي به بلده
ميتا ونسقيه مما خلقنا انعاما واناسي
كثيرا ولقد صرفناه بينهم
ليذكروا اب اكثر الناس الا
كفورا ولو شئنا لبعثنا في كل قريه
نذيرا فلا تطع الكافرين وجاهدهم
به جهادا
كبيرا وهو الذي مرج البحرين هذا عذب فرات
وهذا ملح اجاد
وجعل بينهما
برزخا وحجرا
محجورا وهو الذي خلق من
الماء بشرا فجعله نسبا
وصهرا وكان ربك قديرا
ويعبدون من دون الله ما لا ينفعهم ولا يضر
وكان الكافر على ربه
ظهيرا الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
وما ارسلناك الا مبشرا
ونذيرا قل ما اسالكم عليه من اجر
الا الا من شاء ان يتخذ الى ربه
سبيلا وتوكل على الحي الذي لا
يموت وسبح بحمده وكفى به بذنوب عباده
خبيرا الذي خلق السماوات والارض وما
بينهما في سته
ايام في سته ايام ثم استوى على
العرش الرحمن فاسال به
خبيرا واذا قيل لهم اسجدوا للرحمن قالوا
وما
الرحمن انسجد لما تامرنا
وزادهم
نفورا الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر تبارك الذي جعل في السماء بروجا وجعل
فيها سراجا
وقمرا
منيرا وهو الذي جعل الليل والنهار خلفه
لمن اراد ان يذكر او اراد
شكورا وعباد الرحمن الذين يمشون على الارض
هونا واذا خاطبهم الجاهلون قالوا
سلاما والذين يبيتون لربهم سجدا
وقياما والذين يقولون ربنا اصرف عنا عذاب
جهنم
ان عذابها كان
راما انها
ساءت
مستقرا
ومقاما والذين اذا انفقوا لم يسرفوا ولم
يقتروا وكان بين ذلك
قواما والذين لا يدعون مع الله الها اخر
ولا يقتلون
ولا يقتلون النفس التي حرم الله الا بالحق
ولا
يزنون ومن يفعل ذلك يلقى
اثاما يضاعف له العذاب يوم القيامه ويخلد
فيه
مهانا الا من تاب وامن وعمل عملا صالح
فاولئك يبدل الله
سيئاتهم
حسنات وكان الله غفورا
رحيما ومن تاب وعمل صالحا
فانه يتوب الى الله
متابا والذين لا يشهدون الزور واذا مروا
باللغو مروا
كراما والذين اذا ذكروا بايات ربهم لم
يخروا عليها صما
وعميانا والذين يقولون ربنا هب لنا من
ازواجنا
وذرياتنا قره اعين واجعلنا
للمتقين اماما
اولئك يجزون الغرفه بما
صبروا ويلقون فيها
تحيه
وسلاما خالدين فيها حسنت
مستقرا
ومقاما قل ما يعبا بكم ربي لولا
دعاؤكم فقد كذب ابتم فسوف يكون
لزاما الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
استقيم
اعتدل الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك نستعين
اهدنا الصرا راط
المستقيم صراط الذين انعمت عليهم غير
المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين طا
سم
م تلك ايات الكتاب مبين لعلك باخع نفسك
الا يكونوا
مؤمنين انشا ننزل عليهم من
السماء ايه فظلت اعناقهم لها
خاضعين وما ياتيهم من ذكر من الرحمن محدث
الا الا كانوا عنه معرضين
فقد كذبوا فسياتي
انباء ما كانوا به
يستهزئون اولم يروا الى الارض كم انبتنا
فيها من كل زوج
كريم ان في ذلك لايه وما كان اكثرهم
مؤمنين وان ربك لهو العزيز الرحيم واذ
نادى ربك موسى ان ائت القوم
الظالمين قوم
فرعون الا
يتقون قال رب اني اخاف ان
يكذبون ويضيق صدري ولا ينطلق لساني فارسل
الى
هارون ولهم علي ذنب فاخاف ان
يقتلون قال كلا فاذهبا
باياتنا قال كلا فاذهبا الى ايات باياتنا
الى
فرعون قال كلا فاذهبا باياتنا انا معكم
مستمعون فات يا فرعون فقولا انا رسول رب
العالمين
ان ارسل معنا بني
اسرائيل قال الم نربك فينا وليدا ولبثت
فينا من عمرك
سنين وفعلت فعلتك التي فعلت وانت من
الكافرين قال فعلتها اذا وان من
الضالين ففررت
منكم لما
خفتكم فوهب لي ربي حكما وجعلني من
المرسلين وتلك نعمه تمنها علي ان عبت بني
اسرائيل قال فرعون وما رب
العالمين قال رب السماوات والارض وما بينه
ان كنتم
موقنين قال لمن حوله الا
تستمعون قال ربكم ورب
ابائكم
الاولين قال ان رسولكم الذي ارسل اليكم
لمجنون قال رب المشرق والمغرب وما بينهما
ان كنتم
تعقلون قال لئن اتخذت الها غيري
لاجعلنك من
المسجونين قال اولو جئتك بشيء مبين قال
فات به ان كنت من
الصادقين فالقى عصاه فاذا هي ثعبان
مبين ونزع يده فاذا هي بيضاء
للناظرين قال للملا حوله ان هذا لساحر
عليم يريد ان
يخرجكم من ارضكم بسحره فماذا
تامرون قالوا ارجه واخاه وابعث في المدائن
حاشرين
ياتوك بكل سحار
عليم فجمع السحره لميقات يوم
معلوم وقيل للناس هل انتم
مجتمعون لعلنا نتبع السحره ان كانوا هم
الغالبين فلما جاء السحره قالوا لفرعون ان
لنا
لاجرا اان لنا لاجرا ان كنا نحن
الغالبين قال نعم
وانكم اذا لمن
المقربين فقال قال لهم موسى القوا ما
انتم
ملقون فالقوا حبالهم وع يهم وقالوا بعزه
فرعون انا لنحن الغالب
غالبون فالقى موسى عصاه فاذا هي تلقف ما
يافكون فالقي السحره
ساجدين قالوا امنا برب
العالمين رب موسى
وهارون قال امنتم له قبل ان اذن لكم انه
لكبيركم الذي علمكم السحر فلسوف
تعلمون
لاقطعن ايديكم
وارجلكم من خلاف ولاصلبنكم
اجمعين قالوا لا ضير انا الى ربنا
قلبون انا نطمع ان يغفر لنا ربنا خطايانا
ان
كنا اول
المؤمنين الله
اكبر سمع الله
لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا الض
ضالين
امين فاوحينا الى موسى ان اسر بعبادي انكم
متبعون فارسل فرعون في المدائن
حاشرين ان
هؤلاء ل شرذمه
قليلون وانهم لنا لغ
ظون
وانا لجميع
حاذرون
فاخرجناهم من
جنات وعيون وكنوز ومقام كريم كذلك
واورثناها بني
اسرائيل
فاتبعوهم
مشرقين فلما تراء الجمع
قال اصحاب
موسى قال اصحاب موسى انا
لمدركون قال كلا
ان معي ربي
سيهدين واوحينا فاوحينا الى موسى ان اضرب
بعصاك البحر
فانفلق فكان كل فرق كالطود عظيم وازلفنا
ثم
الاخرين
وانجينا موسى ومن معه
اجمعين ثم اغرقنا
الاخرين ان في ذلك لايه وما كان اكثرهم
مؤمنين وان ربك لهو العزيز الرحيم
واتل عليهم نبا
ابراهيم اذ قال لابيه وقومه ما
تعبدون قالوا نعبد
اصناما فنظل لها عاكفين
قال هل
يسمعونكم اذ
تدعون او
ينفعونكم او
يضرون قالوا بل كذلك قالوا بل
وجدنا قالوا بل وجدنا
اباءنا كذلك
يفعلون قال
افرايتم ما كنتم
تعبدون انتم
واباؤكم
الاقدمون فانهم عدو لي الا رب
العالمين الذي خلقني فهو
يهدين والذي هو يطعمني
ويسقين واذا مرضت فهو
يشفين والذي يميتني ثم
يحيين والذي اطمع ان يغفر لي خطيئتي يوم
الدين رب هب لي حكما والحق ني
بالصالحين واجعل لي لسان صدق في
الاخرين واجعلني من ورثه جنه
النعيم واغفر لابي انه كان من
الضالين ولا تخزني يوم
يبعثون يوم لا ينفع مال ولا
بنون الا من اتى الله بقلب سليم وازلفت
الجنه
للمتقين وبرزت الجحيم
للغاوين وقيل لهم اينما كنتم
تعبدون من دون
الله هل يسمعون هل
ينصرونكم او
ينتصرون فكبكبوا فيها هم
والغاوون وجنود ابليس
اجمعون قالوا وهم فيها
يختصمون تى الله ان كنا لفي ضلال مبين اذ
نسويكم برب العالمين
ما
اضلنا الا
المجرمون فما لنا من
شافعين ولا صديق حميم فلو ان لنا كره
فنكون من
المؤمنين ان في ذلك
لايه ان في ذلك لايه وما كان
اكثرهم
مؤمنين وان ربك لهو العزيز
الرحيم الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه
الله السلام السلام عليكم ورحمه الله
[Silence]
‏oke
بسم الله الرحمن
الرحيم والصلاه والسلام على رسول الله
وعلى اله وصحبه ومن ولاه ومن تبع باحسان
الى يوم الدين اما بعد ان شاء الله
دعا البء
[Silence]
علر ‏one of the
prophets that is mentioned in the bible
as well and he has his own book of speak
literally within the books in the
bible you know it's it's just one page
the jona and the whale it's literally
one page so front and back and it just a
story and in the bible itself there
is a time where jesus talks about jonah
and he mentions as jonah was in the
belly of the fish for three days and
three nights so
‏of man
days earth and propy he was crucified
come
عليه which is in that of not syan
[Silence]
‏sy trans all
‏you
know people benit all the people and
tell exactly why so he goes to the
people and he to convers with them and
they say you know what we don't
listen all
the time for you are
what
telling
come so
‏was ed
[Silence]
‏the
‏st
people urve
[Silence]
‏can bew lots and namees
up don't agree we draw again and he says
telling you the one we still don't
believe you so they draw lots again his
name comes up
again
find be it so the third time said look i
al told you i the person who has dis his
master ‏thow me
over
so willingly he goes willingly overboard
into the water as soon as he thr into
the water a wh comes up and
swallows and the wh then ss to
the now you have the darkness of the
night the darkness of the stm the
darkness of the water and the darkness
of the belly of
the right and there there where is يون
عليه
اللاسلام الله سبحانه
وتالى
الله فنا في ظلماتي ان لا اله الا انت
سبحانك اني كنت من
الظالمين لا اله الا انت سبحانك اني كنت
من الظالمين
[Silence]
اللهه
الله
عليهه
why the hor there
‏com what so look
at whatever in
whatever
clever
it tomorrow i'll remember tomorrow
work whatever i'm not tr i got i my
‏go so what they do is they say okay
everybody let meet in the b you know are
open are outs they bring all of their
farm anals and they separate
every from their so k goats are
separated the goats are sear the cows
and are separated the are separated even
children are sear from mother
الله
[Silence]
‏for
‏other الله
سال الله سبانت 88 الب 21 الله سبحانه
وتعالجنا ل ونجيناه من الغم وكذلك ننجي
المؤمنين
[Silence]
شاء لا اله الا سبحانك انن
منين حث انول
[Silence]
سبالى ان الله
شاى
عليهه
make
as ربنا في الدنيا حسنه وفي الاخره حسنه
وقنا عذاب النار وقنا عذاب القبر وقنا
عذاب جنم وقنا ع وقنا شر فتنه المحيا
والممات وقنا شر فت المسيح الدجال ربنا
تقبل من انك السميع العليم وتوب علينا يا
مولاك تواب الرحيم وصلى الله على محمد
وعلى اله وصحبه اجمعين برحمتك ارحم
الراحمين اللهم امين اللهم امين اللهم
امينك الله
[Silence]
استووا استووا
اعتدل الله اكبر
الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم مالك
يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وان ربك لهو العزيز الرحيم كذبت قوم
نوح المرسلين اذ قال لهم اخوهم نوح الا
تتقون اني لكم رسول امين
فاتقوا الله
واطيعون وما اسالكم عليه من اجر ان اجري
الا على رب العالمين فاتقوا الله
واطيعون قالوا انؤمن لك واتبعك الارذلون
قال وما علمي بما كانوا يعملون ان حسابهم
الا على ربي لو تشعرون وما انا بطارد
المؤمنين ان انا الا نذير
مبين قالوا يا نوح لئن لم تنته لتكونن من
المرجومين قالوا لئن لم تنته يا نوح
لتكونن من
المرجومين قال رب ان قومي كذبون فافتح
بيني وبينهم فتحا ونجني ومن معي من
المؤمنين
فانجيناه ومن معه في الفلك المشحون ثم
اغرقنا بعد الباقين ان في ذلك لايه وما
كان اكثرهم مؤمنين وان ربك لهو العزيز
الرحيم كذبت عاد المرسلين اذ قال لهم
اخوهم هود الا تتقون اني لكم رسول امين
فاتقوا الله
واطيعون وما اسالكم عليه من اجر ان اجري
الا على رب
العالمين اتبنون بكل ريع ايه تعبثون
وتتخذون مصانع لعلكم تخلدون واذا بطشتم
بطشتم جبارين فاتقوا الله
واطيعون واتقوا الذي امدكم
بما تعلمون امدكم بانعام وبنين وجنات
وعيون اني اخاف عليكم عذاب يوم عظيم قالوا
سواء علينا اوعظت ام لم تكن من
الواعظين ان هذا الا خلق الاولين وما نحن
بمعذبين
فكذبوه فاهلكناهم
ان في ذلك لايه وما كان اكثرهم مؤمنين وان
ربك لهو العزيز
الرحيم كذبت ثمود
المرسلين اذ قال لهم اخوهم صالح الا تتقون
اني لكم رسول امين فاتقوا الله
واطيعون وما اسالكم عليه من اجر ان اجري
الا على رب العالمين اتتركون فيما هاهنا
امنين في جنات وعيون وزروع ونخل طلعها
هضيم وتنحتون من الجبال بيوتا فارهين
فاتقوا الله
واطيعون ولا تطيعوا امر المسرفين
الذين يفسدون في الارض ولا يصلحون
قالوا انما انت من
المسحرين ما انت الا بشر مثلنا فات بايه
ان كنت من
الصادقين قال هذه ناقه لها شرب ولكم شرب
يوم معلوم ولا تمسوها
بسوء في ياخذكم عذاب
اليم ولا تمسوها بسوء فياخذ عذاب عظيم
فعقروها فاصبحوا نادمين فاخذهم
العذاب ان في ذلك لايه وما كان اكثرهم
مؤمنين وان ربك لهو العزيز
الرحيم كذب قوم لوط المرسلين اذ قال لهم
اخوهم لوط الا تتقون اني لكم رسول امين
فاتقوا الله واطيعون وما اسالكم عليه من
اجر ان اجري الا على قوم ان اجري الا على
رب
العالمين اتاتون الذكران من العالمين
وتذرون ما خلق لكم ربكم من ازواجكم بل
انتم قوم عادون
قالوا لئن لم تنته يا لوط
لتكونن من المخرجين قال اني لعملكم من
القالين رب نجني واهلي مما يعملون فنجيناه
واهله اجمعين الا عجوزا في
الغابرين ثم دمرنا الاخرين وامطرنا عليهم
مطرا فساء مطر
المنذرين ان في ذلك لايه وما كان اكثرهم
مؤمنين وان ربك لهو العزيز
الرحيم كذب اصحاب الايكه المرسلين اذ قال
لهم شعيب الا تتقون اني لكم رسول امين
فاتقوا الله
واطيعون وما اسالكم عليه من اجر ان اجري
الا على رب العالمين اوفوا الكيل ولا
تكونوا من المخسرين وزنوا بالقسطاس
المستقيم ولا تبخسوا الناس
اشياءهم ولا تعثوا في الارض
مفسدين واتقوا الذي خلقكم والجبل الاولين
قالوا انما انت من
المسحرين وما انت الا بشر مثلنا وان نظنك
لمن الكاذبين فاسقط فاسقط علينا كسفا من
السماء ان كنت من
الصادقين قال رب اعلم بما
تعملون فكذبوه فاخذهم عذاب يوم الظله انه
كان عذاب يوم
عظيم ان في ذلك لايه وما كان اكثرهم
مؤمنين وان ربك لهو العزيز
الرحيم
وانه
لتنزيل رب
العالمين
الله سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت عليهم
غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين وانه لتنزيل رب العالمين نزل به
الروح الامين على قلبك لتكون من المنذرين
بلسان عرب ي
مبين وانه لفي زبر الاولين اولم يكن لهم
ايه ان يعلمه علماء بني
اسرائيل ولو نزلناه على بعض الاعجمين فقرا
عليهم ما كانوا به مؤمنين كذلك سلكناه في
قلوب المجرمين لا يؤمنون به حتى يروا
العذا
الاليم فياتيهم بغته وهم لا يشعرون
فيقولوا هل نحن
منظرون افبعذابنا
يستعجلون افرايت ان متعناهم سنين ثم
جاءهم ما كانوا يوعدون ما اغنى عنهم ما
كانوا
يمتعون وما اهلكنا من قريه الا ولها
منذرون ذكرى وما كنا ظالمين وما تنزلت به
الشياطين وما ينبغي لهم وما يستطيعون
انهم عن السمع لمعزولون
فلا تدع مع الله الها اخر فتكون من
المعذبين وانذر عشيرتك الاقربين واخف
جناحك لمن اتبعك من المؤمنين فان عصوك فقل
اني
بريء مما
تعملون وتوكل على العزيز الرحيم الذي يراك
حين تقوم وتقلبك في الساجدين انه هو
السميع
العليم قل هل انبئكم على من تنزل الشياطين
تنزل على كل افاك اثيم يلقون السمع
واكثرهم كاذبون
والشعراء يتبعهم
الغاوون الم تر انهم في كل واد يهيمون
وانهم يقولون ما لا
يفعلون الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وذكروا الله
كثيرا الا الذين امنوا وعملوا الصالحات
وذكروا الله كثيرا وانتصروا من بعد ما
ظلموا وسيعلم الذين ظلموا اي
منقلب
ينقلبون الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن حمده
الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
ان شاء الله ذ سجده سجده
تلاوه ركعه سجده تلاوه ركعه ان شاء
الله الله اكبر
بسم
الله الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضال
ين
امين
طاسين تلك ايات القران وكتاب مبين هدى
وبشرى
للمؤمنين الذين يقيمون الصلاه ويؤتون
الزكاه وهم بالاخره هم
يوقنون ان الذين لا يؤمنون بالاخره زينا
لهم اعمالهم فهم
يعمهون اولئك الذين لهم سوء
العذاب وهم في الاخره هم
الاخسرون وانك لتلقى القران من لدن حكيم
عليم اذ قال موسى لاهلهم امكثوا اني انست
نارا ساتيكم منها بخبر او اتيكم بشهاب قبس
لعلكم
تصطلون فلما
جاءها نودي ان بورك من في النار ومن حولها
وسبحان
الله وسبحان الله رب
العالمين يا موسى انه انا الله العزيز
الحكيم
والق عصاك فلما راها تهتز كانها
جان ولا مدبرا ولم
يعقب يا موسى لا تخف اني لا يخاف لدي
المرسلون الا من ظلم ثم بدل حسنا بعد
سوء فاني غفور
رحيم وادخل يدك في جيبك تخرج
بيضاء من غير سوء في تسع ايات الى فرعون
وقومه انهم كانوا قوما فاسقين فلما
جاءتهم اياتنا مبصره قالوا هذا سحر مبين
وجحدوا بها واستيقنتها انفس
ظلما
وعلوا فانظر كيف كان عاقبه
المفسدين ولقد اتينا داوود وسليمان علما
وقال الحمد لله الذي فضلنا على كثير من
عباده
المؤمنين وورث سليمان داوود وقال يا ايها
الناس علمنا منطق الطير واوتي من كل شيء
ان هذا لهو الفضل
المبين وحشر لسليمان جنوده من الجن والانس
والطير فهم
يوزعون حتى اذا اتوا على واد النمل قالت
نمله يا ايها النمل ادخلوا
مساكنكم ادخلوا مساكنكم لا
يحطمنكم سليمان وجنوده وهم لا
يشعرون فتبسم ضاحكا من
قولها وقال رب اوزعني ان اشكر نعمتك التي
انعمت علي وعلى
والدي وان اعمل صالحا
ترضاه وادخلني برحمتك في عبادك الصالحين
وتفقد الطير فقال م لي لا ارى الهدهد ام
كان من
الغائبين لاعذبنه عذابا شديدا او
لاذبحنه او
لياتين بسلطان
مبين فمكث غير بعيد فقال احطت بما لم تحط
به وجئتك من سبا بنبا يقين
اني وجدت امراه تملكهم واوتيت من كل شيء
ولها عرش عظيم وجدتها وقومها يسجدون للشمس
من دون
الله وزين لهم الشيطان اعمالهم فصدهم عن
السبيل فهم لا
يهتدون الا يسجدوا لله الذي يخرج الخبا في
السماوات وال ارض ويعلم ما تخفون وما
تعلنون الله لا اله الا هو رب العرش
العظيم الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
قال سننظر اصدقت ام كنت من
الكاذبين اذهب بكتابي هذا فالقه اليهم ثم
تولى عنهم فانظر ماذا
يرجعون قالت يا ايها الملا اني القي الي
كتاب كريم انه من سليمان وانه بسم بسم
الله الرحمن
الرحيم الا تعلوا علي واتوني
مسلمين قالت يا ايها الملا افتوني في امري
ما كنت قاطعه امرا حتى
تشهدون قالوا نحن اولو قوه والو باس شديد
والامر اليك فانظري ماذا
تامرين قالت ان ان الملوك اذا دخلوا قريه
افسدوها وجعلوا اعزه اهلها اذله وكذلك
يفعلون
واني مرسله اليهم بهديه
فناظر بما يرجع
المرسلون الله اكب
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
[Silence]
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين فلما جاء سليمان قال اتمدونني بمال
فما اتاني الله خير مما اتاكم
بل انتم بهديتكم
تفرحون ارجع اليهم فلناتينهم بجنود لا قبل
لهم بها ولنخرجنهم
منها اذله وهم
صاغرون قال يا ايها الملا ايكم ياتيني
بعرشها قبل ان ياتوني
مسلمين قال عفريت من الجن انا اتيك به قبل
ان تقوم من مقامك قبل ان تقوم من مقامك
واني عليه لقوي
امين قال الذي عنده علم من الكتاب انا
اتيك به قبل ان يرتد اليك طرفك فلما راه
مستقرا عنده قال هذا من فضل ربي يبلوني
ااشكر ام اكفر ومن شكر فانما يشكر لنفسه
ومن كفر فان ربي غني
كريم قال نكروا لها عرشها ننظر اتهتدي ام
تكون من الذين لا
يهتدون فلما جاءت قيل اهكذا عرشك قالت
كانه هو واوتي العلم واوتينا العلم من
قبلها وكنا
مسلمين وصدها ما كانت تعبد من دون الله
انها كانت من قوم
كافرين قيل لها ادخلي الصرح فلما راته
حسبته لجه وكشفت عن
ساقيها قال انه صرح ممرد من
قوارير قالت رب اني ظلمت نفسي واسلمت مع
سليمان لله رب
العالمين ولقد ارسلنا الى ثمود اخاهم
صالحا ان اعبدوا الله فاذا هم فريقان
يختصمون قال يا قوم لم تستعجلون بالسيئه
قبل الحسنه لولا تستغفر
الله لعلكم ترحمون قالوا اطيرنا بك وبمن
معك قال
طائركم عند الله بل انتم قوم
تفتنون وكان في المدينه تسعه رهط يفسدون
في الارض ولا
يصلحون قالوا تقاسموا بالله لنبيتنه
واهله ثم لنقولن
لوليه ثم
لنقولن لوليه ما شهدنا مهلك اهله وانا
لصادقون ومكروا مكرا ومكرنا مكرا وهم لا
يشعرون فانظر كيف كان عاقبه مكرهم انا
دمرناهم وقومهم
اجمعين فتلك بيوتهم خاويه بما ظلموا ان في
ذلك لايه لقوم يعلمون وانجينا الذين امنوا
وكانوا
يتقون ولوطا اذ قال لقومه اتاتون الفاحشه
وانتم
تبصرون اكم لتاتون الرجال شهوه من دون
النساء
بل انتم قوم
تجهلون فما كان جواب قومه الا ان قالوا
اخرجوا ال لوط من
قريتكم انهم اناس
يتطهرون
فانجيناه واهله الا امراته قدرناها من
الغابرين وامطرنا عليهم مطرا فسا امطر
المنذرين قل الحمد
لله قل الحمد لله وسلام على عباده الذين
اصطفى الله خير اما
يشركون الله
اكبر سميع الله لمن
حمده الله
[Silence]
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
شاف الوتر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم راط الذين
انعمت عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين والضحى والليل اذا سجى ما ودعك ربك
وما قلا ولا الاخره خير لك من الاولى
ولسوف يعطيك ربك فترضى الم يجدك يتيما
فاوى ووجدك
ضالا فهدى ووجدك
عائلا فاغنى فاما اليتيم فلا تقهر واما
السائل فلا تنهر واما بنعمه ربك فحدث الله
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا الصراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين امين
قل يا ايها
الكافرون لا اعبد ما
تعبدون ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد ولا انا
عابد ما عبدتم ولا انتم عابدون ما اعبد
لكم دينكم
وليدين الله اكبر
سمع الله لمن
حمده الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله
[Silence]
اكبر السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام
عليكم ورحمه
الله الله
اكبر الحمد لله رب العالمين الرحمن الرحيم
مالك يوم الدين اياك نعبد واياك
نستعين اهدنا صراط المستقيم صراط الذين
انعمت
عليهم غير المغضوب عليهم ولا
الضالين
امين قل هو الله احد الله الصمد لم يلد
ولم يولد ولم يكن له كفوا احد
الله
اكبر سمع الله لمن
حمده ربنا ولك الحمد حمدا كثيرا طيبا
مباركا فيه ملء السماوات وملء الارض وملء
ما بينهما وملء ما شئت من شيء بعد اهل
الثناء والمجد احق ما قال العبد وكلنا لك
عبد اللهم لا مانع لما اعطيت ولا معطي لما
منعت ولا ينفع ذا الجد منك الجد اللهم
اهدنا في من هديت وعافنا في من عافيت
وتولنا فيمن توليت وبارك اللهم لنا فيما
اعطيت وقنا واصرف عنا برحمتك شر ما قضيت
انك سبحانك تقضي بالحق ولا يقضى عليك
انه لا يذل من واليت ولا يعز من عاديت
تباركت ربنا
وتعاليت لك الحمد يا ربنا على كل حال لك
الحمد يا ربنا على ما اعطيتنا ولك الحمد
يا ربنا على ما
منعتنا لك الحمد يا ربنا في الاولى ولك
الحمد يا ربنا في الاخره لك الحمد يا ربنا
على كل حال
اللهم اقسم لنا من خشيتك ما تحول به بيننا
وبين معصيتك ومن طاعتك ما تبلغنا به جنتك
ومن اليقين ما تهون به علينا مصائب الدنيا
ومتعنا اللهم باسماعنا وابصارنا وقواتنا
ابدا ما ابقيت واجعله الوارث منا واجعل
ثارنا على من ظلمنا وانصرنا على من عادانا
ولا تجعل مصيبتنا في ديننا ولا تجعل
الدنيا اكبر همنا ولا مبلغ علمنا ولا تجعل
الى النار مصيرنا واجعل الجنه هي دارنا
وقرارنا برحمتك يا ارحم الراحمين اللهم
انصر المسلمين المستضعفين في كل مكان
اللهم انصر اخواننا المسلمين في غزه وفي
كل مكان اللهم ككل لهم يا رب العالمين ولا
تكن عليهم اللهم كن لهم يا رب العالمين
ولا تكن عليهم اللهم اطعم جائعهم واسق
ضمانهم واكس عاريهم واشف مريضهم وارحم
ميتهم وارحم شهدائهم وسدد رمي مجاهد
وانصرنا وانصرهم على عدونا وعدوهم يا رب
العالمين اللهم ص عدوهم عددا واقتلهم بددا
ولا تغادر منهم احدا ربنا انهم مفسدون في
الارض ربنا انهم يهلكون الحرث والنسل وانت
ربنا لا تحب الفساد عليك بهم يا رب
العالمين اللهم انا نجعلك في نحورهم ونعوذ
بك من شرورهم اللهم اجعل كيدهم في نحورهم
واجعل تدميرهم في تدبيرهم واجعل الدائره
تدور عليهم يا رب العالمين وارزقنا نصره
اخواننا المجاهدين اللهم ارزقنا نصره الحق
في اي مكان يا رب
العالمين اللهم اعتق رقابنا من النار
اللهم اعتق رقابنا ورقاب ابائنا وامهاتنا
وازواجنا واولادنا واصدقائنا وكل من له
فضل علينا من النار برحمتك يا عزيز يا
غفار رب اغفر وارحم واعف وتكرم وتجاوز عما
تعلم انك تعلم ما لا نعلم انك انت الله
الاعز الاكرم انك انت الله الاعز الاكرم
سبحان ربك رب العزه عما يصفون وسلام على
المرسلين والحمد لله رب العالمين وصل
اللهم وسلم على نبينا محمد وعلى اله و
صحبه
والتابعين الله
اكبر الله
اكبر الله اكبر
الله اكبر
[Silence]
السلام عليكم ورحمه الله السلام عليكم
ورحمه الله
[Silence]
ان